[Musica]
in ambito informatico
una soluzione parte da una richiesta
iniziale di un cliente che va annotata
va ascoltata va controllata
ricontrollata e con lo scopo di
garantire un servizio di qualità
efficiente bisogna immedesimarsi il più
possibile in un utente o per usarlo per
usare un anglicismo uno user ma che cosa
significa realmente
andare a immedesimarsi in uno user
immaginatevi di andare a sviluppare un
videogioco per ipovedenti che è basato
sul riconoscimento del colore di una
palla da una fotocamera
capisco che al primo ascolto possa
sembrare un vero e proprio paradosso
un'applicazione per non vedenti che si
basa sul riconoscimento di un colore un
qualcosa di prettamente visivo senza
addentrarci in tecnicismi che vi
annoierebbero morte vi basti pensare che
il riconoscimento del colore permette di
attivare un suono tridimensionale che
consenta al giocatore non vedente di
capire dove si trova all'interno dello
spazio alla palla per poterla calciare e
quindi andare a sfruttare allo stesso
tempo all'udito che uno dei sensi
maggiormente sviluppati in un soggetto
ipovedente un altro progetto che è stato
realizzato sulla falsariga di questo è
il digital disable che ha un vero e
proprio una vera e propria simulazione
di un ping pong in realtà aumentata che
consente a un giocatore di giocare di
visualizzare sempre con l'aiuto dell
audio tridimensionale
una pallina e poterla colpire con una
racchetta virtuale per poter testare le
funzionalità di questo videogioco
abbiamo semplicemente chiuso gli occhi
potreste pensare ok veramente molto
semplice chiudere gli occhi
ma non basta il battito di palpebre non
basta per andare a formare una soluzione
valida al cento per cento
nei nostri progetti sostanzialmente la
difficoltà è rappresentata
dalla smi l'azione della domanda più che
dalla complessità della risposta alla
risposta
non è mai realmente complessa se la
domanda viene studiata e capita a 360
gradi mi spiego meglio noi non abbiamo
un'esperienza concreta di cosa voglia
dire non avere il senso della vista
quotidianamente e di conseguenza noi non
possiamo neanche pretendere di avere tra
le nostre mani la soluzione ai problemi
una parte dei problemi di questa cerchia
ristretta di persone
gli unici ad avere in mano
effettivamente la soluzione e sono loro
sono sono i non vedenti ma manca un
pezzo fondamentale è il pezzo
fondamentale è lo strumento il mezzo per
poter comunicare la soluzione a questi
problemi che nel mondo spesso
nel mondo d'oggi non c'è
io penso sinceramente che al di fuori di
qui ci siano tante persone che hanno le
capacità e le abilità e le competenze
potenzialmente di andare a implementare
algoritmi codici e programmi migliori
dei miei ma semplicemente non hanno i
mezzi per poterlo fare
secondo noi sarebbe giusto che tutti
avessimo le stesse opportunità perché
nel mondo le diversità esistono e molto
spesso sono irreversibili non ci
possiamo far nulla ma
immaginatevi la vita come una
lunghissima corsa di velocità
per la quale però sarebbe molto più
giusto partire tutti dallo stesso punto
di partenza senza favoritismi per
nessuno
questo è gerry c'è il ragazzo del nostro
istituto è affetto da tetraparesi
distonica di tipo spastica per la quale
non riesce ad utilizzare gli arti in
modo appropriato
qualche tempo fa c'è stato chiesto da
jerry e dai suoi stessi insegnanti
hanno espresso il desiderio di un
dispositivo in grado di aiutarlo
nell'attività didattica e nelle azioni
quotidiane scolastiche che normalmente
per lui sarebbe impossibili
oppure molto difficili se non aiutato è
stato di conseguenza avviato un progetto
che attraverso l'intelligenza
artificiale è un programma lo aiutino a
scrivere a
studiare lo aiutano anche a spostare il
cursore sul monitor con lo sguardo
fantastico direste voi tuttavia
non è esattamente una vittoria cioè si
per genere e una vittoria a tutti gli
effetti ora è molto più autonomo
rispetto a prima però c'è qualcosa di
intrinseco e triste nella stessa
richiesta del progetto se gerry non
aveva un supporto e perché nessuno
glielo aveva mai dato
al giorno d'oggi
soprattutto negli ultimi anni e nello
scorso la nostra generazione
è stata messa di fronte
alla potenza dei mezzi comunicativi
nel senso che adesso noi giovani
conosciamo quanto sia facile reperire
delle informazioni in internet on line
quindi siamo noi giovani le persone più
appropriate un futuro a fornire a capire
innanzitutto e poi a fornire delle
soluzioni
ha dei problemi di certe classi
ristrette di persone come gli ipovedenti
oppure come le persone più in difficoltà
come jerry
ecco che
però al giorno d'oggi
questa cosa non c'è
non viene mai valutato da un'azienda o
da un'impresa un progetto per solo
aspetto morale ma
bene espresso sul trattato soltanto un
interesse per l'aspetto economico quanto
può impattare sui profitti aziendali
quanto
questo progetto può essere utile agli
scopi economiche della mia azienda
tuttavia
proviamo immedesimarci un attimo in un
imprenditore un imprenditore
profondamente restio un imprenditore
molto legato al suo capitale ecco lui
non vedrebbe nulla ti di guadagno nel
progetto come quello di gerry non
vedrebbe assolutamente nulla se non una
perdita di tempo
tuttavia che ci dice che da un progetto
piccolo per una singola persona non
possa nascere qualcosa di grandissimo
vi faccio un esempio
credo che tutti avete riconosciuto il
personaggio in foto lui è stephen
hawking
probabilmente uno dei più grandi
divulgatori scientifici e fisici teorici
della storia dell'umanità e fin quando
non ci piove
nel 1963 conobbe una malattia
degenerativa dei motoneuroni che lo
condannarono ad una vita in sedia a
rotelle ecco ci vuole poco
per capire che quell intelletto che il
genio aveva non poteva rimanere
inespresso
a tal fine degli scienziati e degli
ingegneri si sono uniti per sviluppare
un progetto
che è un sistema in grado di riconoscere
il micro movimenti della bocca di
rocking quel poco che c'è da fare
tradurre in parole e successivamente
esprimermi attraverso una voce la
famosissima voce che un peter izzat a di
woking
questo accadde nel 1985 nel
1985 un periodo storico nel quale un
progetto del genere non era sicuramente
economico e tanto meno facile da
realizzare
tuttavia gli ingegneri ci riescono in
particolare particolarmente in tempi
ristretti dando una voce finalmente
all'uomo che poi ha divulgato ha
divulgato tantissimo questo è un esempio
di come un progetto per una singola
persona
può cambiare la storia dell'umanità come
alla fine è avvenuto
e se ci fossero altri migliaia di
hawking altri milioni di hawking
nascosti
imprigionati nelle loro gabbie di
inesprimibile intelletto
scienziati atleti perché no scrittori
che hanno e chi più ne ha più ne metta
che hanno semplicemente bisogno di un
dispositivo in grado di dare un braccio
una voce una gamba una mano un dito
c'è da dire che gli scienziati e gli
ingegneri informatici ed elettronici
eccetera che hanno lavorato al sistema
comunicativo di rocking sono stati
profumatamente ricompensati a dir poco
però credo che la ricompensa più grande
è quella del genere umano
quindi
la vera domanda è siamo sicuri che sia
solo una questione di soldi
il ragazzo
[Applauso]
[Musica]